me gustaría que se quedara bastante
claro este problema pues en el vídeo
pasado estaba yo en el límite de tiempo
y ya no supe que tan claro que don
nosotros lo que teníamos era la razón
entre la cantidad de huevos de color
blanco y la cantidad de huevos de color
arena ya habíamos dicho que esa relación
eran dos tercios por una parte y de aquí
lo que hice fue despejar a la cantidad
de huevos blancos para verla en relación
a la cantidad de huevos de color arena y
por lo tanto pase los huevos de color
arena
del otro lado multiplicando de tal
manera que me quedo que la cantidad de
huevos blancos es igual a 2 tercios la
cantidad de huevos de arena esto por una
parte pero por otra parte yo sabía que
la cantidad de huevos totales que hay en
la canasta es la cantidad de huevos
blancos más la cantidad de huevos color
arena esto es la cantidad de huevos
totales esto es muy importante nosotros
tenemos en la canasta solamente huevos
de color blanco y huevos de color arena
por lo tanto la cantidad total es la
suma de estos 2
y lo que hice fue sustituir la cantidad
de huevos de color blanco en donde dice
ven para que todo me quede expresado
como la cantidad de huevos de color
arena pero esto es lo mismo que el total
es decir que el total de la cantidad de
huevos que va a haber en la canasta lo
podemos ver como cinco tercios de la
cantidad total de huevos de color arena
que va a ver que es justo lo que yo
escribí aquí el total de huevos que va a
haber en la canasta lo podemos ver como
cinco tercios del total de la cantidad
de huevos de arena que va a haber y
ahora si yo multiplico ambas partes de
esta igualdad por tres quintos por tres
quintos aquí y por tres quintos aquí
entonces este se va a ir con este este
saber con este y me va a quedar que la
cantidad de huevos de color arena que va
a haber en la canasta es igual a tres
quintos de la cantidad total de huevos
que va a haber en la canasta y bueno ya
con esto lo que quiero que veas es que
estamos buscando un valor que no sea
factible para la cantidad de huevos de
la canasta
si no es factible tiene que ser un
número que no sea divisible entre 5
porque nosotros lo que estamos buscando
es un número que sea entero y positivo
no podemos tener huevos quebrados
literalmente no podemos tener una cierta
cantidad de huevos en fracción por lo
tanto lo que estamos buscando es que
este número este de aquí sea un número
entero y para que sea un número entero
necesitamos que forzosamente el valor de
la cantidad total de huevos sea
divisible entre 5 y después vimos en las
respuestas que el inciso b no es
divisible entre 5 y por lo tanto esa fue
nuestra respuesta correcta así que bueno
movámonos al siguiente problema voy a
borrar esto y voy a tomar el color verde
para contarte el siguiente problema que
por cierto es el problema número 7 si 18
por la raíz
1818 en la raíz de 18 es lo mismo que
ere por la raíz de t por la raíz de t y
con la condición de que sea más grande
que te y tanto ere como te sean
positivos y sean enteros esto es muy
importante que sean enteros
entonces cuál de los siguientes incisos
es un valor válido para la
multiplicación de r por ti y bueno cómo
le podemos hacer para resolver este
problema
date cuenta que r no puede ser 18 y de
18 no se puede quedar esto igual porque
yo quiero que ere sea más grande que t
la forma que se me ocurre es un poco
larga creo que eso no será lo más
factible
vamos a ver porque esta es la raíz raíz
de 18 creo que se puede simplificar un
poco más vamos a ver si la puedo
simplificar un poco más raíz de 18 esto
es lo mismo que la raíz de 9 por 2 9 por
2 y bueno esto por propiedad de las
raíces es lo mismo que la raíz de 9 por
la raíz de 2 pero la raíz de 9 es 3
entonces me queda que esto es lo mismo
que tres veces la raíz de dos y bueno
esto es la raíz de 18 pero originalmente
tengo esto tengo esa expresión de aquí
entonces 18 18 raíz de 18 es lo mismo
que 18 por tres veces la raíz de 2
y 3 por 18 esto es lo mismo que 3 por 8
24 y llevamos 23 por 13 y 2 54 54 la
raíz de 2 y bueno ahora que ya
simplifique la raíz de 18 date cuenta
que en este caso r toma el valor de 54
es este número de aquí mientras que t
te toma el valor de 2 y bueno lo que
nosotros queremos saber es la
multiplicación de el reporte vamos a ver
si de pura casualidad cuando estos dos
números obtengo esa multiplicación y
reporte y que estén los incisos es lo
mismo que 54 por 2 que es 108 y vamos a
ver si los incisos está haciendo 8 si
esta es el inciso c perfecto es justo lo
que yo quería
encontré la multiplicación de reporte de
tal manera que r sea mayor que t ambos
sean positivos ambos sean enteros y
cuando tal vez tendremos que verificar
qué
los incisos no sean realmente esta
multiplicación de 18 raíz de 18 sin
embargo creo que con esto funciona
bastante bien y vámonos al siguiente
problema entonces problema número 8
problema número 8 y tenemos un triángulo
adentro de un triángulo así que tomemos
el color amarillo me gusta el color
amarillo para este problema primero
tengo un lado como éste después tengo
otro lado como este y después tengo otro
lado como este y después adentro de éste
tengo un triángulo muy parecido a éste
tengo algo así
así y algo así muy bien y me dicen
déjame poner otro color deja manejar
otro color este ángulo vale ve este vale
se esté vale am
este balde b
uno espera que fue este vale ve también
esto también vale ven y este vale a me
dan todos estos ángulos y lo que me
preguntan es cuánto vale c en términos
de be idea yo lo que quiero saber es
cuándo vale c en términos de idea bueno
si has visto mis vídeos de geometría
sabes que este triángulo adentro de este
triángulo lo conozco como el juego de
los ángulos porque esencialmente lo que
hay que hacer tenemos que averiguar la
mayor cantidad de ángulos pero con mucho
cuidado fíjate bien por ejemplo si yo
hablo de este este ángulo este ángulo es
lo mismo que quién bueno pues aquí tengo
180 grados porque estos tres ángulos son
suplementarios pero aquí ya tengo dos b
entonces me quedaría 180
los dos ve este ángulo de aquí también
podríamos averiguar este ángulo de aquí
y este ángulo de aquí lo que este ángulo
de aquí no me serviría mucho aunque de
todas maneras lo voy a poner aquí es 180
menos a menos c pero cuáles son los
ángulos que me importan mucho creo que
éste me va a servir este de aquí quién
es bueno este ángulo es lo mismo que 180
menos a menos b este de aquí bueno por
otra parte este ángulo de aquí es igual
a quien este ángulo de aquí va a ser
igual a 180 porque estamos hablando de
un triángulo 180 menos am - ven ok
este de aquí es 180 menos a menos ven y
este este de aquí y que por cierto nos
va a servir bastante este de aquí quien
es bueno este de aquí por una parte
180 grados menos 180 grados menos este
menos este está de acuerdo es 180 menos
esta parte de aquí porque son ángulos
suplementarios es decir 180 ya esto le
voy a quitar 180 menos a menos b 180
menos a menos b que es esta parte de
aquí y a esto le voy a quitar este
pedacito de aquí que por cierto es menos
180 menos a menos b también muy bien
entonces también estoy quitando este
pedacito de aquí que por cierto cuánto
es todo esto voy a hacerlo con este
color esto es lo mismo que 180 menos 180
más
ve menos 180 más y más ve y de aquí este
con este se puede cancelar y me quedan 2
am más 2 b menos 180 este ángulo de aquí
es lo mismo que dos a más 2 b menos 180
pero ojo aquí viene otra cosa muy
importante este ángulo también por otra
parte tiene que ver con este triángulo
de aquí arriba y este triángulo de aquí
arriba tiene aquí a ve aquí hace y me
falta este ángulo es decir que este
ángulo también lo podemos ver como parte
de este triángulo como 180 menos b - c
entonces qué creés estoy encontrando que
por una parte este ángulo mide 2 más 2 b
menos 180 esto porque estamos hablando
de ángulos suplementarios y me tomé 180
menos este menos
por otra parte me estoy dando cuenta que
este mismo ángulo vale 180 - bm no sé
por qué es parte de este triángulo
entonces le estoy quitando ce y le estoy
quitando b entonces llegó a esta
igualdad esto es lo mismo que 180 menos
ven menos ce y si de aquí quiero el
valor de s expresado en términos de ahí
deben lo que tengo que hacer es despejar
hace así que vamos a despejar hace que
te parece si primero paso este para
camps y me va a quedar y este también lo
voy a pasar una vez para acá y me queda
2 am éste va a pasar con signo positivo
estoy sumando b de ambos lados de esta
igualdad y me queda 2 a más 3 b entonces
está bien le quite y ahora este 180 lo
voy a pasar del otro lado o voy a restar
180 de ambos lados de esta igualdad y
entonces éste lo voy a pasar y me queda
menos 360 esto es igual
a menos cuidado con los signos y ahora
si yo lo que quiero es el valor de ese
positivo en términos de ahí debemos voy
a cambiarle a todo esto los signos voy a
multiplicar por menos 1 y me va a quedar
que se ya positivo es lo mismo que 360
menos 2 am menos 3 b lo único que hice
fue cambiarle a todos de signo para
obtener así el valor de ese y ya está
este es mi valor de este de este
problema en términos de a y de b el cual
encontré igualando este ángulo dos veces
en primer lugar lo tomé con este
triángulo y el segundo lugar lo tomé con
estos ángulos suplementarios y ya está y
perfecto solamente hay que recordar que
de aquí paso para camps y solamente hice
todo es utilizando propiedades de los
triángulos así que ya está ya tengo aquí
mi problema número 8 y vamos a hacer
creo que me da tiempo de hacer el
problema número 9
así que voy a ponerlo aquí este va a ser
mi problema número 9 y hemos llegado a
la sección de preguntas abiertas
pero esto está muy fácil dice si te
ubican si te kubica es lo mismo que 351
cuánto vale o cuánto es cuánto
es cuatro veces de kubica y bueno hay
dos formas de resolver esto la primera
sería despejando de aquí a t después
elevarlo al cubo y multiplicarlo por
cuatro pero creo que esa no es la forma
óptima o la más fácil de resolver este
problema si yo sé que y déjeme apuntarlo
aquí abajo si yo sé que te kubica es
igual a 351 que te parece si ahora
multiplicó por 4 ambos lados de esta
ecuación por 4x4 para llegar a tener 4 t
kubica que sus lo que yo quiero y
entonces 4 t kubica es lo mismo que 351
por 4 y cuánto es eso vamos a hacerlo
aquí 351 lo voy a multiplicar por 4 y
esto es lo mismo que 4 por 144 por 520
llevamos 24 por 312 y los dos que
llevábamos son 14 mil 404 4 t cúbica es
mil 404
y ya está aquí tengo mi respuesta así
que ya se me acabó el tiempo y les
seguimos en el próximo vídeo